une fois par semaine coraline se rend
chez madame jaussaud oui c'est la femme
de ménage elle est employée par une
agence spécialisée dans l'aide à
domicile ici sa mission est de faire le
ménage pendant deux heures chaque
mercredi matin
je vais vous aider pour le losc je suis
obligé parce que je ne peux pas tout
faire
il est pour eux et lever les bras pour
que j'ai plus de difficulté mais plus
qu'une aide ménagère coraline se fait
aussi régulièrement offrir le café par
madame jaussaud elle le fait de passer
du temps avec eux de pouvoir aussi on
parle de nos vies
on est vraiment un lien avec les clients
en plus du fait qu'on leur apporte notre
aide pour le ménage
si madame jaussaud est encore en pleine
forme pour faire sa cuisine et ses
courses ce n'est pas toujours le cas des
seniors qui peuvent tendre vers une
perte d'autonomie
forte de ce constat et du lien que nous
leur quarantaine de salariés avec leurs
clients seniors lagence plaisir was a
décidé d'étendre l'activité tête
ménagères un réel accompagnement en
quatre axes alliés saveurs et nutrition
cultiver les liens intergénérationnels
prévenir les risques domestiques
enfin travailler sa mémoire et on est
vraiment sur une prise en charge globale
mais toujours en faisant ensemble et pas
à la place de puisque l'idée est
naturellement de préserver l'autonomie
des personnes âgées et aime bien qu'il
soit en perte d'autonomie progressive et
donc de les maintenir à leur domicile ce
qui est leur souhait l'agent selon cette
nouvelle prestation après deux ans
d'installation à plaisir et interviendra
également sur les communes de ville
prouver les clayes-sous-bois une manière
aussi de lutter contre l' isolement
selon le ministère des solidarités de la
santé 50 % des personnes de plus de 75
ans n'ont plus de réseau amical actifs